déjà s'être assise et les jeunes
itinérants qui vivent dans la rue avec
un chien ou un chat subissent les
critiques et les préjugés
enfin la grande question c'est le style
des soins adéquats leur animal on en
parle ce matin avec le docteur
vétérinaire jean gauvin bonjour docteur
gauvin vous l'avouer
vous avez été de ceux qui croyaient que
les itinérants ne devrait pas avoir
d'animaux pensez peut-être les gens qui
les maltraitaient quel que soit
exactement fait pas nécessairement qu'il
est mal traitée de façon voulu mais qui
s'en occupait pas de façon optimale
or la docteure lem qui fait sa maîtrise
à l'université de guelph là dessus en
2012 qui a prouvé exactement le
contraire en fait si ces études qui vous
on se changeait tout effectivement en
fait c'est vraiment elle qui m'a fait
changer d'idée au départ est à ottawa
présentement elle a des cliniques pour
les jeunes de la rue justement
puisqu'elle l'a fait mander afin de
prouver que les jeunes ne m'entraînais
pas leurs animaux
l oms l homme a fait une étude sur cinq
simples des animaux qui venait à sa
clinique de façon aléatoire puis elle a
fait un indice de poids corporel par
s'est aperçu que la grande majorité de
ces animaux là avait des indices de
poids corporel supérieur à la moyenne
ce qui veut dire que ces gens là c est
inhérent le qui étaient dans la rue
s'occupait plus même de leur animal que
de même donc le principe c'est mon
animal d'abord et avant tout donc des
animaux en santé finalement exactement
c'est certain que les soins vétérinaires
sont limitées ça dépend des villes à
travers le canada puis tout ça mais pour
ce qui est de l'animal comme tel il est
effectivement bien nourris bien traités
et pour comprendre pourquoi ils sont
bien nourris bien traité malgré on
s'entend des ressources limitées de ces
itinérants pour comprendre en fait le
rôle que jouent ces animaux dans leur
vie oui on puis c'est un rôle très
important c'est un support émotionnel
fantastique
ses seuls animaux le seul amour
inconditionnel qu'ils ont jamais connu
dans la plupart des cas on va avoir une
diminution significative de consommation
d'alcool chez ces jeunes là 2
dur aussi ça leur donne aussi une raison
de vivre
c'est pas banal parce que 65 pour ça des
jeunes de la rue ont pensé au suicide
donc leur animal de compagnie va
diminuer deux des principales causes de
mortalité chez les jeunes de la rue la
consommation de drogues dures et le
suicide c'est vraiment important donc et
on a une diminution aussi du taux de
criminalité
donc c'est important pour la société
c'est important pour ces jeunes parce
que c'est vraiment une relation pour
peut-être la seule relation de confiance
qu'ils réussissent à bâtir pendant ces
périodes de ces périodes difficiles
vous dites baisse de la criminalité
expliqué nous c'est parce que il ya un
risque parce que ces jeunes ne veulent
pas se faire votre peau se faire
embarquer par les policiers parce que si
c'est le cas ils perdent leur animal de
compagnie dont tous les petits larcins
qui pourrait y avoir par exemple on ne
va pas les faire même chose pour la
diminution de la consommation d'alcool
parce que s'ils sont ivres sur la voie
publique
ils vont se faire embarquer leurs chiens
parce qu'avant c'est dans un refuge il
ya un gros risque qui perdent donc ces
jeunes là ça les responsabilise
énormément et c'est une chance
supplémentaire de pouvoir de pouvoir
donner une chance à ces jeunes autorités
green vie normale
mais bon il ya en effet un pervers un
lot côté de la médaille en fait si ces
animaux là je prends deux chiens 6-2 un
chien à être beaucoup un jeune itinérant
en même temps il le nu
nuit un peu avoir un toit effectivement
parce que la relation entre l'animal de
compagnie que ce soit un choix un rat ou
un chien est tellement forte que
beaucoup de ces jeunes qui vont refuser
des services qui leur sont offerts
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de refuge à
montréal puis ou à travers le canada qui
refuse à une autre compagnie sont rares
la note bleue montréal seulement auquel
a banker qui est sûr dans la rue puis
aussi le refuge des jeunes donc
l'organisme dans la rue acceptent des
animaux mais les conditions il va
vraiment une intervention des
particuliers lui absolument en fait ce
que ce que les légendes dans la rue
veulent à pierre raison pourquoi ils ont
accepté les animaux c'est qu'ils sont
aperçus effectivement ils vont sûrement
se tait pops à l'époque ils sont aperçus
que les jeunes embarqués pas dans le
système de dans la rue qui est un
système de réintégration qui leur
montrent comment par exemple travailler
un stud et mêlée genia l'époque parce
que leurs ennemis pouvait pas y aller et
c'est pour ça donc comme une entente
entre les jeunes de la rue leurs animaux
et les légendes par exemple dans la rue
ou où il ya une clinique une fois par
mois justement pour pour les aider du
clic vétérinaire gratuite qui est
organisé par l'université de montréal en
collaboration avec dans la rue et puis à
ce moment là pour que ces jeunes là et
le droit à ces services là ils doivent
s'impliquer dans le système de dans
leurs rangs quelques secondes itno
quelle serait la solution aucun registre
est la prochaine étape
il faudrait que les politiques changent
pour qu'on puisse avoir de plus en plus
de refuge qui vont accepter les animaux
ça protégerait encore plus et je ne veux
comprendre n'importe relation lors que
ces gens là ont avec leur animal on
vient vraiment de changer la perception
ont presque devenus des gens quand ils
vont voir un jeune dans la rue avec un
animal auront plus le même regard et
c'est ce que j'espère parce que
présentement ils sont ostracisées
docteur vétérinaire jean gauvin merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec ma reprise et
bonne année bonne année à vous